depuis houston avec dave perkins
animateur radio analyse politique
supporters de donald trump c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors si
on en lit ce rapport sur cette attaque
contre le capitole du 6 janvier
finalement on nous dit ça aurait pu être
évité ce que c'est votre avis également
je ne le pense pas je pense que l'ordre
à la police de n'être pas intervenir de
ne pas déployer leurs arbres puissantes
sont venues des niveaux les plus élevés
du parti démocrate je pense que nancy
pelosi a ordonné à la police du capitole
de se tenir en retrait car elle voulait
utiliser cet événement dans le cadre de
son programme anti trust antirépublicain
et on a bien vu maintenant qu'ils ont
dressé des barricades déployer de
manière permanente la garde nationale
nancy pelosi affiche son inquiétude face
à donald trump et à ces manifestants
qualifié de terrorisme domestique
il est évident d'après les vidéos que
les policiers se sont mis en retrait ont
même introduit les manifestants dans le
bâtiment ont ouvert les portes et ce ne
sont pas les images d'un jeu partement
de police se défendant contre l'invasion
de terroristes dirais plutôt qu'il
s'agissait d'une mise en scène qui
seraient utilisés plus tard comme outil
de propagande alors le procès a montré
également que cet événement était tumen
planifié mais il semblerait que certains
manifestants voulaient juste participer
une dernière manifestation pro trump de
manière pacifique mais d'autres vivait
au contraire vouloir empêcher la
certification du scrutin et punir les
prêtres inde du congrès ça s'est
retourné contre ses premiers manifestons
by pacifique
nombre de mes amis étaient présents
j'ai reçu des détails très précis de ce
qui est arrivé devant le capitole j'en
suis certain des personnes dans cette
foule à avaient été introduits afin de
la rendre plus violente que si les
choses s'étaient développées tout seul
il y avait des membres dans tifa dans
cette foule
il essayait de pousser à la violence de
pousser à l'insurrection
on ne l'a ni festin on ne souhaitait pas
pénétrer dans le capital ne souhaitait
pas finir les le concret il voulait fait
rien de violent qui puisse être moins
sur le dos des pacifistes
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas d'autres
partisans pro trump qui ont fait des
bêtises il et les actes est le plus
grave la violence la plus forte a qu'une
brutale que l'on voit sur les images il
semblait bien que cela soit le fait de
personnes qui n'étaient pas des
partisans de donald trump
les partisans de dallas 30 le savent et
moi et aussi car je me suis rendu là de
nombreux rallyes dans le passé je ne
pense pas que les partisans de 30
étaient les responsables des plus gros
acte d perkins on va revenir sur cette
information dont on parlait il est tout
juste quelques minutes un le
gouvernement baden qui avait suspendu la
vente d'armes aux émirats arabes unis
conclu en novembre par donald trump et a
finalement elle va me poursuivre ce
contrat on attendait des changements de
joe biden quelle est votre réaction
beaucoup de choses que donald trump est
il ici et que joe biden et son
administration continue qu'il s'agit de
la politique vaccinale de politique
étrangère comme les gendarmes
donc les émirats arabes unis joe biden
est bien content que donald trump est
réussi
pousser une normalisation des relations
avec israël ce qui permet cette vente
d'or mais il faut se rappeler que
l'argent ne revient pas aux états unis
mais revient ou fabricants de ces armes
les personnes qui ont construit ce et
ses avions ses drones ces projectiles
cet argent les entreprises s'attendait à
la recevoir arrêts et des donateurs
républicains et démocrates voulaient
donc cette vente se fasse et ne
souhaitait pas que verizon l'empêcha et
joe biden n'a pas trouvé de bonnes
raisons pour empêcher cette vente est
effectivement pour moi il n'y a pas de
bonnes raison d'empêcher cette vente car
les émirats arabes unis doit pouvoir se
protéger à l'avenir contre des amis
comme l'iran au niveau régional alors
vous le savez aussi les émirats arabes
unis qui sont impliqués dans le conflit
au yémen qui tue beaucoup de civils par
conséquent beaucoup critiquant ses
ventes d'armes aux émirats arabes unis
vous ne pensez pas qu'il aurait fallu
que joe biden la coupe puisque lui
justement est prompte souvent aux leçons
de morale certain côté je les pense
effectivement il serait logique que john
hayden le dise je suis meilleur que
donna truax nous sommes une
administration plus morale que
l'administration trump
nous devons empêcher cette vente pour le
bien des civils au yémen mais aux états
unis la plupart des gens ne savent pas
qu'ils sont le combattant dans le
conflit du yémen ne savent pas cuisiner
son souffre parce que les médias
américains ne prennent jamais le temps
d'expliquer la situation que yémen
correctement donc cet amendement pour
l'amour pour le public américain et je
pense que l'administration bailleul
comprends qu'on peut mettre en danger
les 6
il est l'unique renforçant l'armement
des miracles car le public ne comprend
pas et ne leur reprochera pas toujours
au niveau international joe biden qui a
annoncé le retrait avec quatre mois de
retard par rapport au calendrier de son
prédécesseur de retrait des troupes en
afghanistan
finalement on se rend compte et vous
l'avez d'ailleurs un petit peu dit qu'il
ya assez peu de changements il n'y a pas
une grosse rupture entre les deux
administrations en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la politique étrangère
[Musique]
après tout la compétence nécessaire pour
faire son travail des gens qui font le
travail pour lui les gens qui me
disaient qui prend ses décisions
sa fille que donald run était un
dirigeant raisonnable à mesurer qui
avait de bonnes raisons pour ses actions
et qu'elle est à l'encontre des
décisions de la trump juste parce que
c'était les siennes est en général une
mauvaise stratégie
ils doivent trouver une façon
d'expliquer à leurs électeurs pourquoi
ils font la même chose que de la trempe
là il s'agit là de deux maux il faut
présenter la situation de manière
lénifiantes ont fait une spécialité des
démocrates
il se sent très bon lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une relaxé les gens de l'échantillon
et après avoir tant lutté contre donald
trump effectivement et les
problématiques qui continue dans cette
voie merci beaucoup d'effets perkins à
d'avoir arrêté avec nous en direct sur
ft france ce soir